if you today it's monday by sunday night
i challenged you to come up with uh some
sort of activity or business where you
could make a thousand dollars per week
what would you do
without any of our unfair advantages
correct
just starting from scratch you want to
make a thousand dollars per week what do
you do
gosh i think probably the easiest thing
to do uh because it's it's not that hard
is like go to anybody who's a media
persona i'm sure like like you or me
and start creating content based on
their content for them i think you could
not just make a thousand dollars a week
you could make thousands like i have
people who ping me sometimes radically
like memes let's say for twitter or
they'll ping me like a little video of
just my stuff chopped up like even if
i'm not a good talent i would just go
and watch a bunch of your stuff and then
i would get on fiverr and get a designer
a video editor based uh somewhere
offshore and i would send you like three
to five videos like hey do you like
these if so awesome use them um you know
and if you think they're interesting
enough i'd love to to create more
content for you we everyone i know is so
hungry for content um and we all make a
lot of money on the internet and
otherwise i think it's a no-brainer to
become an outsourced content creator you
could create an agency in like five
minutes i mean um it's wild yeah that's
a pretty good answer i think one time
before we thought of um
what did we say uh you could go if you
want to make a thousand dollars one time
for the weekend uh you probably you'd
have to hustle but you could go make a
couple hundred bucks as a golf caddy etc
the problem is that a lot of those uh
they're not very scalable and also uh
they're very difficult because they
require some sort of physical
uh labor etc uh and then in some way
like
the payment is kind of a tip right so
like you know maybe you get a good tip
or maybe you don't with this it's pretty
clear uh you're running an actual
business you can scale and also you can
set price which uh ends up being a much
better business to be in than like hey i
want to go make some extra cash as a uh
as a caddy
yeah i agree maybe the other thing if
you want to go more manual than tech
would be like um like i might just like
go buy a power sprayer or something from
home depot actually could probably just
rent one and run around like a nice
neighborhood uh somewhere in your city
and ask if you can power wash people's
driveways like oh this looks kind of
dirty do you need some power washing on
this uh you can't really screw up a
driveway so i don't think you could you
know i wouldn't power wash a house to
start with but that would probably be a
really quick way if i was a a young kid
to run around a neighborhood and do
something like this services are really
hard to get right now for almost
everybody i mean we got a quote from a
pool guy yesterday for 400 a month to
clean our pool um so anything where you
can make somebody's house nicer and
easier and serve them like this i think
you could probably make some money
really quick how big is your pool you
gotta pull the size of the ocean for a
hundred dollars to just come and clean
it it's the littlest pool this is like
this is not a mansion it's just austin
has such an influx of people
that we can't get somebody who can put
us in the rotation um and they're like
well maybe we could do it if we paid 400
i was like i'm about to learn about pool
cleaning that's not happening hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time